depuis l'annnonce du conte film en
espagne le 14 mars dernier la majorité
des étudiants étrangers sont rentrés
dans leur pays
certains toutefois ont été contraints de
rester à barcelone parce que leur vol ou
autre moyen de rapatriement ont été
annulés d'autres comme louise étudiante
française de 21 ans ont choisi de rester
par choix je suis resté ici tout
simplement parce que je voyais pas
l'intérêt de rentrer en france ça
faisait quelques temps que ça fait à
peine deux semaines que j'étais arrivé
j'avais envie de pas de continuer mon
expérience ici je venais à peine de
découvrir un peu l'endroit de découvrir
les gens et j'ai eu la chance d une
résidence étudiante donc plein de
mélange de cultures de parler de poires
par les anglais de pouvoir parler
espagnol
lorsqu'elle est arrivée début mars sa
résidence étudiante à barcelone comptait
plus de 300 locataires ils ne sont plus
qu'une trentaine à y loger aujourd'hui
mais malgré ces conditions particulières
la jeune femme se veut optimiste plus
qu'au début de mon expérience ici j'ai
envie de voyager envie de voir les
choses positivement j'avais de me dire
que la plage va réouvrir rapidement
qu'on va pouvoir aller faire des les
soirées tranquillement avec avec les
potes et puis et puis voilà et puis on
verra au fur et à mesure ça serait au
rire gras et puis il faut rester positif
talent le confinement
ces trois étudiants français aussi le
connaissent bien avant d'arriver à
barcelone il était qu un semestre
d'études à shanghai
confiné dès le mois de janvier en chine
est pressée de rentrer par leurs proches
inquiet par l'épidémie il avait
finalement décidé de quitter le pays fin
janvier pour revenir en europe
destination barcelone mais deux semaines
après leur arrivée
l'espagne déclaré le confinement le plus
strict transmettrait repoussée parce que
parce qu'on a quitté la chine pour
profiter du semestre
content qu'on avait donc ouais ben ça
forcément il ya un peu de frustration
tout ça après après voilà on reste
toujours positif comme on l'a été en
chine et on se dit ça va s'améliorer
malgré que on retrouve que les les
mesures sont de plus en plus plus en
plus strictes et elles seront
progressives et perdure dans le temps
c'est pas c'est pas une carburation
banques
ceux qui suivent un cursus sont passées
au cours à distance avec les différentes
écoles et université de barcelone
d'autres effectuent leur stage en
télétravail en espagne les cours dans
l'enseignement supérieur ne reprendront
sans doute pas avant la rentrée
prochaine